it's a biden cover-up at the border the
white house is trying to hide the truth
about
what's really going on and we know now
why
they've been blocking the media from
seeing it firsthand
shocking new photos from inside a texas
facility show
horrific conditions for migrant children
crammed into little plastic cages
one pod is at nearly twice the capacity
and is holding more than 400
unaccompanied male
minors the white house claims it's
working on giving reporters access
while the dhs secretary says we might
just have to take the biden
administration's word
for it number one
let's not forget that we're in the midst
of a pandemic
and we are focused on our operations
executing our operations in a crowded
border patrol
facility where hundreds of
vulnerable migrant children are located
number one
and number two we're working on
providing footage
so that the american public can see uh
the border patrol stations
so we're supposed to rely on the white
house that says it's not a crisis to
show what's what's happening
it's ridiculous but don't worry
president biden has everything under
control and says
he'll eventually get down to the border
are you thinking of going to the border
at some point i will yes
do you want to see firsthand what's
going on in those facilities
i know what's going on with facilities
i'm not really sure he does all right
janine you were just down at the border
tell us what you saw down there
well it is a mess but i have to comment
on mayorkis you know for this guy to
claim
you know there's covet it's a pandemic
we can't let anybody go down we got to
protect the children
this guy is either disingenuous or is
lying because these children are not are
not even being tested
for covid uh in addition to that um
for him to say that you know we're
working on it these kids are in
lucite cages with some kind of you know
a blanket that's made of foil and the
bottom line is
that they're now being sent into the
interior
but they're being kept longer than 72
hours
which is outside of the requirements 2
000 kept longer than 72 hours 800
kept longer than 10 days they're not
following any of the guidelines
everything they complained about when
the president trump was in office
they're doing but they're trying to hide
it from us they're trying to say
don't believe your lying eyes we're
telling the truth they're not telling
the truth they're lying and if when i
talked to border
patrol when i was down there they said
it's a nightmare
that they are the ones who are being
subjected to coven
that they don't even feel the border
patrol and the sheriffs like they're
part of america anymore
people in the southern towns that border
mexico
don't feel like they even matter to the
united states
that they can be infected that they can
be harmed
that the cartels are coming in no one is
protecting them
it is a nightmare
dana the bush administration obama
administration
trump administration they all let the
press take photos at the border patrol
everyone was allowed access now for the
one time joe biden says no no no
we're gonna prohibit press access i
don't see how they can blame a pandemic
for that you put a mask on
you go there take a picture from 20
yards away yeah
we're all working we've all been able to
you know you covered the protests
um journalists have been covering
everything from the super bowl
to other things so okay i'm not gonna
buy that
if henry cuellar who's the congressman
who released those photographs
had worked in the administration as a
career official they would call him a
whistleblower
but why would he do this yeah he would
do it because he's trying to raise the
alarm
as i understand it he's very frustrated
it feels like the white house is not
listening to him in fact
susan rice a domestic policy adviser
slash
maybe semi national security advisor
went down there for a meeting they
didn't even tell him didn't
organize anything with him he's always
frustrated so he now we get to see
and and this is a whole thing that was
wholly preventable
by the biden administration in addition
to that i think that
because thursday's press conference is
an action forcing event
meaning that the press office is going
to tell the chief of staff or the prime
minister
uh here's here's 20 questions the
president needs to be able to answer
by thursday to me those are not just all
communications questions so they better
have a better answer about this in terms
of media access
but this is one in terms of policy they
have a communications problem this is
true
but that's only because they have a
policy problem they got to fix the
policy problem so they can deal with the
other thing
the communications is secondary actually
the policy is the real issue
the easy way juan to fix the policy
problem is just to say
teams aren't allowed in they're going to
have to wait in mexico or somewhere else
i mean that solves about 50 percent of
the problem right there
well it's just not in keeping with who
we are is our history in terms of asylum
and particularly in terms of children
jesse
but you know i can't help but wonder why
all this hyper ventilating sky is
falling
and i got to believe you know trump puts
out a statement over the weekend
and it's all about trying to drag down
his successor joe biden who's a very
popular president i mean
but you know trump says oh the wide
administration just had to
keep doing what we were doing you know
just had to maintain it would have been
fine
then it wouldn't given incentives to
people to come uh
wrong trump had four years
of failed immigration policy inhumane
treatment
breaking apart the asylum system i mean
uh
you know he did away with the central
american miners program we were trying
to do it
he cut aid to el salvador cut aid to
honduras cut aid to
guatemala so made situation there worse
and gave people all the more reason
to want to come here so yeah i mean
what's troubling
i said what's obvious to me is we have a
problem on the border
and we have a surge right now that
rivals what trump experienced in 18 and
19 and it may exceed what trump
experienced the wall street journal
editorial page this morning said you
know the way that we can
actually deal with this rationally is if
congress would get involved and fix the
problem by
updating the asylum rules expanding
migrant worker protections and visas
but the democrats and the republicans
they seem to enjoy
you know sticking it to each other
rather than getting busy solving this
problem i think they think it stirs up
voters jesse but it's
to me it's it's just a horrible
situation i wish we could fix it
yeah it's easy to fix i just said how to
do it greg what do you think
yeah but what you said jesse isn't in
keeping with who we
are right having a border isn't in
keeping
of who we are having a process isn't in
keeping of who we are
just let every teenager in that's who we
are
and that entices them to come with with
adult smugglers
who then by some reason know their
families and can actually use those kids
to do what they want later
because that's what happens when you're
under the power of a criminal cartel
i want to return to the past we had a
president whose transparency
allowed us to see the reality of the
border
so what was biden's solution rather than
solve for that reality
he removed the transparency and again
and it took a month for the media to
figure this out right you know
now we have these poor kids looking like
baked potatoes we should have seen this
a long time ago
and now it's dawning on them oh wow
where are the parents where did the
parents go
remember we kept saying how trump was
separating kids from parents but
it's really clear that somebody else is
separating the parents and it returns to
the simple truth
there is no good answer for the
situation like this
and that nuance and complexity was
missing uh
when trump was president but now they're
affording it to biden
oh my god this is much more complicated
and it's really trump's fault
but actually trump had to deal with
these caravans
while the media and the democrats were
inciting them to come over in order to
poke holes in his immigration policy
because there's no way they could let
him succeed where are all the sanctuary
city heroes now when biden's in charge
they aren't getting their photo op
and it's just to me it's the weirdest
thing
is that they believe keeping migrants in
mexico
is bad because in fact the cnn described
mexico as squalid
that's what they described it so here
you have a party in a press that does
that describes america as racist
it's telling people now you can't keep
them in mexico
they have to come to this racist country
so apparently mexico is inferior to the
united states
it's squalid isn't that racist
i would call that whole opinion racist
all right good points all around up next